oui
joris brams
hu
[Musique]
comme tony stewart
ouahbi
[Musique]
jo
mais je vendais siège également
terme de deuil
au lycée
piquet jr
[Musique]
surtout
des stocks
oh
[Applaudissements]
mystère
[Musique]
chris kaman
je dispose
[Musique]
la
partie
[Musique]
comme ivoire bronzino
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la douleur elle m'est devenu très
familière ces derniers temps
celle qu'on ressent quand on est sans
cesse blessé par la même personne
[Musique]
tu fais que parler de certaines depuis
jour où je t'ai rencontré site est
l'accueil aller avec toi j'espérais
quand déménagerait à londres après la
remise des diplômes et comment j'étais
un ciel devenu
il n'y a que dans ses rares moments où
il m'attire contre sa poitrine il me
fait des promesses qui n'est jamais
capable de tenir
la douleur disparaît ainsi un
c'est tout
sb
revenez plus tard
les relations amoureuses c'est compliqué
tu as un super job qui t'attend seattle
mais là-bas pour moi y'a rien tu
m'aurais moi ok mais ça suffit pas si je
ne suffit pas c'est ton problème mais tu
ne vas pas m'arrêter
j'abandonne pas seattle pour toi alors
tu me fais payer
[Musique]
tu fais ça tout le temps tu gâches tous
les bons moments passés ensemble rhône
je suis pas en train de cacher un bon
moment j'ai juste sortie numéro d'un
autre mec de tes affaires c'est pas toi
tu es sider et qui fait l'annoncé pas
être ami avec toi tu voles plein mais
non
je sais pas quand c'est vrai ça ne l'est
pas
ça suffit on arrête lorsque nous aimons
nous sommes tous des idiots
je voulais te guérir mon temps
tu es l'endroit que je préfère thèse
mais qu'est ce que vous faites là toutes
les deux et halloween on a fait le tour
du quartier vous êtes tout seul il ya un
mec celle où avec un masque blanc qui
arrêtent pas obligé d'essayer de jouer à
cache cache avec nous il craint où vous
l'avez vu ce titre
google
c'est votre
ouvrait la porte à l'est
[Applaudissements]
bon
la tuer michael
ma grand-mère amif
personne ne vous a rien dit
michael myers est toujours en vie
aucun homme n'aurait pu survivre à cet
incendie
il y à 40 ans le croquemitaine venu pour
nous tuer nous sommes les rescapés de
michael meier sais quoi mais on la
france maman c'est à nous de le tuer on
va le traquer et mettre fin à tout ça
il ne s'arrêtera pas de tuer tant qu'on
me laissera faire
au regard doux michael n'a frappé ou
peut être sublime
qui mène droit sa maison d'enfance
ya quelqu'un qui rentre et chinois
il vient me chercher
et c'est moi qui vais trouver
et vas tu as quelqu'un pâte et michael
je veux lui retirer son masque et voir
dans ses yeux la vie qui sait
147 jour depuis le déluge seuls les
animaux qui ont la chance de trouver une
place sur l'arche ont survécu tu peux me
dire ce que c'est que ça c'est la même
chose d'hier et celui là pareil mais en
version prier pendant qu'ils dégustent
ma cuisine il se déguste pas entre eux
c'est vrai non
[Musique]
des vins où sur les enfants
la tête
[Musique]
et réveillé hier vous êtes des must
rayons mais je n'avais jamais vu
d'autres mais ce triomphe l'arche et
lacoste et au pk on est mal ou ne
devrait pas les aider comment vont-ils
quand il n'y aura plus rien du caillou
nous pas des cailloux vous
tu veux nous jeter directement entre les
dents de tes amis tu arrives à ses
larges nous a appris quelque chose c'est
bien qu'il ne faut jamais jamais
chatouilleur ni propos tam non dave on
nous a appris que c'est tout à fait
possible pour nous les animaux depuis
passé nos différences
[Musique]
si tu vraiment tant pis si monster
j'ai raté un épisode
[Musique]
ma fille arrêtée dans réussite est un
exemple pour nous tous elle au final
four a baissé deux fois
tu l'as est allé d'un seul coup de poing
tout frais ou quoi à l'état captera
grande je suis pas passé les poules
j'ai peut-être une idée pour ça l'argent
à la fin du mois je passe pour un
tournée en belgique à 300 milliards
trois cent mille
nietzsche et parfois sérieux frérot
excellent mais
bon voilà c'est quoi ton confort
phénomène toi
[Musique]
du coup
[Applaudissements]
bonjour je vends police judiciaire vous
êtes alexandre farrell mais qu'est ce
que vous vous battez vous êtes tout seul
et si monsieur louis ont procédé à une
perquisition
vous pouvez vérifier s'il vous plaît
c'est forcément une erreur demain je
rentre chez moi aux états unis enfin
plus maintenant
je suis maître un tueur célérier votre
avocat commis d'office ce que tu cesses
qu'entre proches disent que j'ai vu
l'une vie vous reconnaissez les faits
qui vous sont reprochés non elle était
consentante ma fille a porté plainte
pour viol quand à ton fils au cip ça n'a
aucun sens une enquête est en cours vous
êtes placé sous contrôle judiciaire vous
pourriez vous retrouver en prison notre
fils on sait sûrement une folle et
sylvain vraiment bio les plaintes et
rend compte que deux lignes à norme peut
mentir parce qu'il a peur parce que la
réalité de ses actes lui paraît
insupportable gérer en fait c'est un
cauchemar vous l'avez suivi de vote il
m'avait dit qu'il avait un couteau et
vous a menacé avec son couteau ce sont
seulement des questions danoise elle
vous dit qu'il a prononcé ces mots ce
soir ce alors si le rapport sexuel était
consenti trouviez-vous la loire dino
alice madness que vous en voulez
c'est non violence d
sa vie va être foutu la ville qui est
clair il a vécu là est foutue tarikhi
[Musique]
ma prof de danse elle va proposer un
stage de dengue à londres où la voyez
d'action train de grandir ici mais tu
nous met devant le fait accompli
franchement pire celle ci c'est le
confiance
je t'aime bien rencontré le petit copain
de l'hiver
et à 26 ans l'été où cette nuit avec
thil toute la famille cordelle à tous de
toi ou ton est vrai des lecteurs
digestif
ça ressemble pas à une fugue elle est
sous son emprise complètement ils
manipulent les jeunes filles tombent
amoureux dans ce qui les pousse à se
constituer
ouais ouais
je vois pas qu'il a retourné le cerveau
là je l'aimais c'est l'homme de ma vie
inédit fugueuse la série choc de la
rentrée bientôt sur tf1 et découvrez dès
à présent l'intégralité de votre série
sur salto point fr